Problem 23.
Mario drives 1,500 miles
every month.
Which line plot correctly
represents Mario's total miles
driven over a period
of 6 months?
So it's 1,500 miles
every month.
So this is per month.
So every month-- after 1 month
he should drive 1,500 hundred
miles, and that looks
pretty good there.
So after another month, it
should be another 1,500.
Which goes to 3,000.
Right?
After 2 months, he should
drive 3,000 miles.
So far, choice A looks
pretty good.
So I'm just going
to circle that.
Now let's just verify
that the other ones
aren't describing this.
So in choice C, it takes him
6 months to go 1,500 miles.
That's not what they
said, they said
1,500 miles every month.
After 1 month here, he only
went-- I don't know.
He only went 250 miles
or 5-- so this is
definitely not the case.
Choice B shows he started off
having traveled 1,500 miles
and it never changes.
So he doesn't travel anymore.
So it's definitely
not choice B.
And then choice D, after 1 month
he travels 9,000 miles.
Which is completely wrong.
They set it up per month
he travels 1,500 miles.
Definitely not choice D.
So choice A we can
feel good about.
Let's go to the next page.
All right.
We have problem 24.
The temperature on a mountain
peak was 7 degrees Fahrenheit
at 6:00 PM.
By 8:00 PM, so 2 hours later,
the temperature had dropped to
0 degrees Fahrenheit.
If the temperature continued
to drop at the same rate,
which is the best estimate of
the temperature at 11:00 PM?
So what happened?
We went from 6:00
PM to 8:00 PM.
That was 2 hours, right?
And our temperature went from
7 degrees to 0 degrees
Fahrenheit.
So over 2 hours, we
dropped 7 degrees.
Or you could say the rate of
droppage of our temperature,
if you want to say it that
way, so you could say 7
degrees-- let me write
it this way.
7 degrees for every 2 hours.
Or you could say minus 7 degrees
for every 2 hours,
we're dropping.
Or that's the same thing as
saying we're going minus 3.5
degrees per hour.
That's the rate at which
it dropped from
6:00 PM to 8:00 PM.
Minus 3.5 degrees per hour.
So they say, what is the
best estimate of the
temperature at 11:00 PM?
Well, 11:00 PM is going to be
another 3 hours after 8:00 PM.
And if we're dropping at minus
3.5 degrees per hour, and
we're going to do that
for 3 hours, we just
multiply the two.
So you have-- do it over here.
You have minus 3.5 degrees per
hour, and then times 3 hours.
Right?
That's how long we're going to
go from 8:00 PM to 11:00 PM.
The hours cancel out, if
you want to make sure
your units work out.
But what's minus 3.5 times 3?
Well, let's just write it out.
So 3.5 times 3.
I could put a minus there.
We'll worry about
it in a second.
5 times 3 is 15.
3 times 3 is 9, plus 1 is 10.
We have exactly 1 number behind
the decimal point.
We have no decimals here.
We have 1 number behind the
decimal point in our answer,
and then we have a negative
times a positive, which is
going to be a negative.
So from 8:00 PM to 11:00
PM, we're going to
drop by 10.5 degrees.
Now, they say that the
temperature was 0 at 8:00 PM.
So if we drop 10.5 degrees from
that, we're going to be
approximately at minus 10
degrees Fahrenheit.
They say, what is the
best estimate?
If they said exactly, we would
say, oh, minus 10.5 degrees.
If you wanted to do this-- you
could have done this in your
head if you like, but I think
it's nice to say, oh, we're
dropping 3.5 degrees per hour, 3
hours later it's going to be
a little over 10 degrees, or
10.5 degrees, that we dropped
from the 0 degrees at 8:00 PM.
Problem 25.
Do it in-- maybe orange.
Brad bought a $6 binder and
several packs of paper that
cost $0.60 each.
If his total was $13.20,
how many packs of
paper did Brad buy?
All right.
Let's say he bought
p packs of paper.
So how much did he spend?
He bought a $6 binder, so he
spent $6, plus $0.60 per pack
times the number of
packs he bought.
Right?
So this is the total. $6 for the
binder plus $0.60 for each
of the packs.
If you bought 10 packs, we can
do 10 times $0.60 per pack,
but we don't know what it is,
so we just leave it as p.
And the total cost was $13.20.
So we just have to
solve for p.
How many packs of paper
did Brad buy?
So if we subtract 6 from both
sides of this equation-- do it
in blue-- just subtract this
6 from both sides.
You get 0.6p-- maybe I'll
write it like this.
Minus 6, plus there, and then
minus 6 right there.
Just to show you I'm doing the
same thing to both sides of
this equation.
This minus 6 and that positive
6 cancel out, and so you're
just left with a 0.6p on
the left-hand side.
Is going to be equal to 13.2,
or $13.20 minus $6.
You can write that
way if you like.
13 minus 6 is 7.
So it's going to be
$7.20, or 7.2.
And then to solve for p, we just
divide both sides by 0.6.
So if we divide both sides by
0.6, the 0.6's is cancel out
on the left-hand side, so you're
just left with a p.
So you're left with--
do it over here.
p is equal to 7.2
divided by 0.6.
So let's work this out.
0.6 goes into 7.2-- I'll throw
in some trailing 0's.
Now, division by decimals.
This is sometimes a little bit
confusing, but you just have
to remember, you take the number
that we're dividing
into the other number, and you
make it into a whole number.
So you shift its decimal
point, in this
case 1 to the right.
So it just becomes a 6.
Since you shifted its decimal
point 1 to the right, you have
to shift this guy's decimal
point 1 to the right.
So it'll go right there.
So 0.6 into 7.2 is the same
thing as 6 into 72.
Or you could just do
this as a fraction.
You multiply the top and the
bottom by 10, is the same
thing as 72 divided by 6.
And that's just exactly
what we did here.
So 6 goes into 72-- well,
actually, even better, 6 goes
into 7 one time.
1 times 6 is 6.
And then 7 minus 6 is 1.
Bring down the 2.
6 goes into 12 two times.
2 times 6 is 12.
You get a 0.
All 0's left.
So you get exactly 12 times.
And if you know your 6 times
tables, you knew that.
72 divided by 6 is 12.
So p is equal to 12.
He bought 12 packs of paper.
Next problem.
What is the value of this
thing, 3 plus 5 squared,
divided by 4 minus x plus
1, when x is equal to 7?
So let's write it down
when x is equal to 7.
So this becomes 3 plus
5 squared-- so let me
just write it out.
5 squared is 25.
Divided by-- and so they want us
to do a little bit of order
of operations here.
So parentheses are the
dominant role here.
So this thing, 3 plus 25,
this is going to be 28.
So parentheses take the dominant
role here, so this is
going to be a 28 right there.
So let me write it down.
Parentheses are the most
important, then exponents,
then multiplication and
division, and if there's a tie
you go left to right, and
then you do addition and
subtraction.
So they're clearly trying to
make sure that we understand
our order of operations.
So let's do the things
in parentheses first.
So it's 3 plus 5 squared is
3 plus 25, that's a 28.
Then you have an x plus 1.
They're telling us
that x is 7.
This is a 7 plus 1, so that's
going to be an 8.
And then we do the division
before we do the subtraction.
So this becomes 28--
let me rewrite it.
28 divided by 4, minus 8.
And so order of operations,
we do this first. So 28
divided by 4 is 7.
And then we have the 7 minus
that 8 right there, which is
equal to minus 1.
So that is choice B.
Next problem.
Problem 27.
What is the equation of
the graph shown below?
So we just have to figure out
its slope and its y-intercept.
In general, these are
all in kind of the
classic mx plus b form.
y is equal to mx plus b, where
m is the slope, b is the
y-intercept.
The slope here, our
rise over run.
For every 1 we run,
we rise up 1.
For a change in x of 1, we
have a change in y of 1.
So slope is equal to change
in y over change in x,
or rise over run.
We rise by 1 when we run by 1.
So it's equal to 1/1 which
is equal to 1.
So m is equal to 1, and in
every situation here
our slope is 1.
So that didn't help us so far.
But then b is the y-intercept,
where we intersect the y-axis.
And you could see, just from
inspection, that's it.
y is equal to 3.
So we look for b is 3.
So our equation is going to be y
is equal to 1 times x, which
is just x, plus the
y-intercept of 3.
So y is equal to x plus 3,
which is right there.
No more problems on that page.